if the universe created
two-dimensionally large Universe with
all the rest rolled up and small you
couldn't have organisms in that Universe
to ask the questions wow you'd need at
least three and then let's say you had
four spatial dimensions then you have
the problem of things drift away from
each other in such a way that it's hard
to have organized systems so just like
Neil is describing a two-dimensional
creature isn't aware of the third
dimension but if they became aware they
could just kind of float away from their
City you have more volume of space to
fill the cross section for interaction
goes down so now if you add another
dimension the cross section for
interaction goes down again sorry no but
we we successfully exist in three
dimensions in spite of the challenges
the two-dimensional creature would face
upon accessing a third dimension right
so why maybe three's optimal why don't
four-dimensional creatures pity us
foreign
[Music]